the second amendment is taking center
stage in the battle for the white house
president trump in the key swing state
of ohio today where he launched a
scathing attack against joe biden
it comes on the heels of new york's
attorney general filing a lawsuit to
dissolve the national rifle association
for alleged
financial impropriety president trump
accusing the former vice president of
embracing
a radical left-wing agenda against gun
ownership
take a look he's following the radical
left agenda take away your guns
destroy your second amendment no
religion know
anything hurt the bible hurt god
he's against god he's against guns
he's against energy
biden adding some fuel to the fire by
supporting
an assault weapons ban and president
trump claiming on twitter quote
if biden becomes president your great
second amendment
doesn't stand a chance all right the
second amendment issues pete when these
start to take front and center you
people's
their ears perk up and i heard from some
democrats in pennsylvania today
that think that the new york action was
actually going to backfire
on democrats because it will make people
remember that the second amendment is on
the line
it might and it looks like a targeting
of a very effective political advocacy
group in the nra
but here's the thing i've got a guy who
i buy guns from in new jersey and it's a
common refrain is
barack obama is the best gun salesman
america ever had because of his threats
to reduce the second amendment
he said he's never seen people
first-time gun owners
come out to buy personal protective
firearms that he has in the last couple
of months you can't find a firearm
it's because when you have the covet
situation when you have lawlessness in
our streets
individual citizens left center or right
realize ultimately if you want to
protect your first amendment life and
liberty
uh you ultimately need the ability to
defend yourself
and so president trump yes we're in a
covid moment yes the economy matters
matters but he understands cultural
issues are king as well
god guns texas gold energy you know
religious liberty
the ability to defend yourself and
whether or not we'll allow industry to
thrive
is a a front and center kitchen table
issue for a lot of people
and the second amendment if you want to
have a debate about it joe biden wants
to take it away
donald trump wants to preserve it that's
one he believes and a lot of people
believe is a winner for him
emily tell me a little bit about this
lawsuit and what they're alleging in
terms of financial improprieties
at the nra and suggesting it should be
dissolved
right and also an answer to your
question to pete dana
a lot of it has to do with timing now
the new york attorney general is
alleging financial impropriety
essentially that for the last three
years
the corporate leadership at the nra has
been diverting funds
for personal use she called it brazen
illegality
so the question remains why now why this
timing and it seems pretty obvious that
it's for strategy
in an election year given their
investigation has gone back years but i
do note
in addition to what pete said that it's
sort of questionable strategy
joe biden was already leading in the
polls without this being a front and
center issue and this just seeks to
disturb the moderates
and sort of more right democrats comfort
level with joe biden
i have to point out too recall on march
10th when joe biden was touring a fiat
chrysler plant
and a worker approached him and said on
camera you are actively trying to end
our second amendment rights and take
away our guns
to which biden replied you are full of
expletive
i did not no no i'm not trying to take
away your second amendment i support it
but his messaging now
where he calls to memory for american
people how he quote took on the nra
and his policies about mandatory
buybacks and registration and smart gun
ownership
certainly beg to differ and the nra does
not support those policies
one i also noticed that the president
today suggested that joe biden
um is not religious that he wants to he
said hurt god he doesn't believe in the
bible
and the biden the bidens themselves you
know them i want to give you a chance to
talk about this but
the the biden campaign putting out a
statement today
we've shortened it a bit but let me let
me read most of that to you if they
could put that on the screen for me that
would appreciate it because
he basically said joe this is andrew
bates he's a spokesperson
joe biden's faith is at the core of who
he is
he's lived with it with dignity his
entire life and it's been a source of
strength and comfort in times of extreme
hardship donald trump is the only
president in our history
to have tear gas peaceful americans and
thrown a priest
out of his church just so he could
profane it and a bible for his own
cynical optics as he sought to tear our
nation apart
at a moment of crisis and pain
let me get your reaction to that
you know dana it's just so disappointing
to me
uh because joe biden really is
a catholic he is a regular
worshipping catholic and he has gone
through some terrible times in his life
i think everybody knows about the loss
of his son
but he lost his first wife i mean and
joe biden has regularly said
that his faith in god sustained him
through these
very difficult dark episodes in his life
this is not like somebody who just
recently said i've come to jesus
and this is not someone who is using it
as a political tool
this has been his consistent personality
uh all the time that he has been in
politics
so i i just find it so harmful and
disappointing but i note to you dana
that
earlier today vice president pence was
out there he was going after
supreme court chief justice john roberts
saying that john roberts the
conservative chief justice has been a
disappointment to evangelicals
and here on fox today there was a trump
campaign spokesperson saying
michelle obama is complaining that the
coronavirus and the
difficult economic times have her down
maybe she should go to church
and i've got to think to myself wait a
second so the trump campaign now they're
not only
saying oh let's talk about culture wars
issues br dragon guns and joe biden
is not for taking anybody's second
amendment rights away
he's about assault weapons and i think
it's clear
70 of americans agree with him
i i'm just saying pete 70 of americans
agree that's not a radical position
and it's the same thing if you stop and
think about something like the border
wall he wants to drag in most americans
don't support that but they're dragging
in everything
so they don't have to talk about the
president's failure to deal with
coronavirus
lawrence you've been out and about you
having a chance to go and
much more than i have but haven't really
even left my uh
porch here but i i wonder what you think
about these issues you know
when you start to talk about the
cultural issues how do you think that
those play into
the 2020 election in the middle of
coronavirus the pandemic and racial
strife
well i think it's a combination of
culture and policy and i think the
difficult part that the biden campaign
is going to have is
a lot of these attacks for example
immigration he once supported some of
these policy positions for example when
you talk about the border wall or border
fencing
he supported that he was also against uh
employers
hiring illegals he was also against
sanctuary cities and so
the biden campaign is going to have to
figure out how they're going to pivot
against donald trump
if they're on a debate stage and he
tries to call him out and trump says
well you supported that too or if they
decide to have an oppo
research team run ads about that now to
pivot to what's happening in new york
uh and why i think that's a bad strategy
is when
whenever there's a case that the state
brings there has to be a victim
and if the allegations were true about
the nra's leadership
then the victim would be the 5 million
members of the nra
and so they didn't go come out and say
you know what let's protect those
members because
those those funds that they were sending
every month for them to fight for
their second amendment's rights we want
to fight for those people
they decided to not only go after the
leadership which they say allegedly
mismanaged uh funds but they also said
you know what we want to disband
the entire organization right and so
they overplayed their hinder if they had
a little bit of strategy
they would have just targeted the
leadership
that's an it's a very interesting point
no doubt we're going to be talking a lot
about it going forward